my name is Smith Ephraim onic and today
I'd love to tell you a little bit more
about what I've been working on this
past year so if you've ever been to a
classical concert you're probably
familiar with a music program it's
usually paper and includes the pieces
that will be played the composer and
maybe some background info the lab I'm
working with the music technology lab at
MIT is trying to revolutionize the
concert going experience and provide a
new interactive program called concert
cue so what happens is a concert goer is
listening to the piece and provided
relevant pieces of information as the
piece progresses so in the beginning
they might receive some background
information and then halfway through the
piece they might get their attention
drawn to some repeating melody or the
informs that some trumpet section is
coming up so the way this works is a
technique called audio synchronization
where we have a reference recording in
the database which has been annotated
with beats and relevant information and
currently a human operator that sits
there and taps out the beats in the live
setting so my project focused on
automating this process and figuring out
how we can take in the live audio in a
concert setting and have the computer
tell us which beat we're on so there are
a couple different approaches to this
problem and they all involve online
variants of a audio synchronization
algorithm called dynamic time warping so
I surveyed many of these algorithms and
decided to implement them they were
mostly theoretical before so
implementing them was a lot of fun and
took some work to actually make it work
in a live setting and then I got the
opportunity to try out one of these
algorithms at the Boston Symphony
Orchestra a couple weeks ago with very
promising results essentially the beat
that the computer predicted we were on
in the live piece matched perfectly with
the human operator so it looks like this
will be able to kind of work well with
the application and I look forward to
seeing that integration happen